diese clips beginnen natürlich immer
erst an der stelle wo die polizei aktiv
wenn wie jetzt gerade in düsseldorfer
clip sehen da muss man sagen dieser
jugendliche 15 jahre alt ist hat er 13
ist polizeibekannt es gibt vorwürfe
wegen gefährlicher körperverletzung
bedrohung nötigung diebstahl
das heißt er ist total polizei bekannt
und man muss wissen er hat völlig
unmotiviert polizeiwachen angegriffen
sie gingen gegen eine gruppe von zehn
randalierern vor zu denen er eigentlich
gar nicht gehörte er hat sich dann ein
gemisch polizisten angegriffen wurde
daraufhin zu boden gebracht
man muss immer aufpassen dass man täter
und opfer da nicht auch immer irgendwie
ja vermischt denn er hat er wird sagen
die ursache überhaupt für die festnahme
setzt trotzdem ist natürlich total
richtig dass die polizei sich vernünftig
und eben auch vorschrift von raum
verhält und in düsseldorf das gerade
geprüft dass es noch sehr strittig bei
der sache in frankfurt muss man deutlich
sagen
er tritt ein polizeibeamter in den
tatverdächtigen hinein
das geht gar nicht man sieht auch sofort
auf dem video wie eine polizistin
wegschiebt dieser vorfall ist auch
polizeiintern noch vor veröffentlichung
dieses videos gemeldet worden
das heißt auch die anderen kollegen
haben die nicht geschützt sondern sind
sofort zum vorgesetzten gegangen und
haben diesen vorfall gemeldet dort wird
auch ermittelt intern und das wird
vermutlich auf eine gefährliche
gefährliche körperverletzung im amt
hinauslaufen
und dann muss man auch wieder die zahl
sehen in hamburg auch david jost das sei
nur einer zu schnell mit seinem ist
guter gefahr
auch da sagt die polizei das stimmt so
nicht das war zwar die ursache es sollte
gestoppt werden wegen einer
ordnungswidrigkeit und dann hat er
daraufhin die polizisten er wollte sich
nicht ausweisen als sie dann seien auch
aussehen wollten und ihn festhalten
wollten hat er um sich geschlagen und
daraufhin es auch so viel verstärkung
gerufen worden und dann wollte man ihn
zu boden bringen weil er sich weiterhin
geweigert hat seinen ausweis zu zeigen
und da beginnt natürlich das video erst
das heißt also die vorgeschichte sieht
man immer nicht und man sieht alle drei
fälle sind völlig unterschiedlich
gelagert aber vielleicht noch mal ein
satz zum thema racial profiling
innenminister hat man so schön gesagt ja
wenn die drogendealern aufbauen auf
einmal hauptsächlich farbige sind es ist
ja unsinnig dass polizeibeamte anfangen
die die oma zu kontrollieren mit ihrer
handtasche dort verläuft das heißt man
muss eben auch sagen dass häufig eben
taten verübt werden wie auch in den
fällen immer des widerstandes relativ
häufig um überproportional von jungen
männern mit mir
technischen hintergrund in die meistens
auch polizisten sehr aggressiv los und
deswegen ist das natürlich eine
öffentlichkeit manchmal das gefühl naja
die gehen immer nur bestimmte klientel
vorbei muss ich mache meine frage
stellen
wir haben es ja auch wir sehen in
stuttgart bei den ausschreitungen geht
vielleicht auch diese gruppe gegen
polizei anders vor was ist da die
ursache was ist die wirkung und mit so
einem diffamierenden und ba scharf
umrissenen video hilft sicher nicht der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk den
polizisten und auch der gesellschaft
nicht weiter